did you guys was it ever discussed  having any of the Netflix characters  ever in the movie or no I'm kidding  yes we talked about all that stuff but  you can see how many characters there  are in the film it's very difficult when  you've got shows that are being written  while we're also trying to create movies  that are not happening on the same just  from a production standpoint at the same  time as the shows are being produced  it's impossible for us to you know  correlate story between you know three  or four other Marvel films that were  borrowing characters from and then to  add in the TV shows on top of it it just  it just becomes you know an experiment  that would break and and so we felt that  the best way to tell this story was just  stay with the Marvel Cinematic you